مجالات للذكاء الاصطناعي من الامثله على
المجالات التي يتم استخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي فيها
الطب حيث ترى تطور كبير في القطاع الصحي
من خلال الجراحات التي يتم فيها استخدام
روبوتات تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي
الامن السيبراني وفيه تستخدم انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي للتعرف على الهجمات الالكترونيه
والتهديدات الاخرى
التسوق الالكتروني
وفيه يتم توفير توصيات شخصيه للناس بناء
على امثله سابقه لبحثهم وعمليات الشراء
البحث عبر الانترنت اذ ان محرك البحث
يعتمد على مدخلات كبيره من البيانات
لتقديم نتائج البحث المطلوبه
المساعد الرقمي
المساعدون الرقميون كما هو الحال في
الهواتف الذكيه التي توفر خدمات المساعده
للاجابه على الاسئله او تنظيم الروتين
اليومي
مجالات متعدده توجد ايضا مجالات اخرى
يستخدم فيها الذكاء الاصطناعي كالزراعه
والصناعه اضافه للسيارات ذاتيه القياده
عمل اكثر اخطاء اقل وربما تكون الميزه
الاكبر للالات العامله بالذكاء الاصطناعي
انها تستطيع العمل دون انقطاع كما انها
تقلل من هامش الخطا البشري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات